[Music]
hi my name's Allen Pattillo I'm your
fisheries and aquaculture extension
specialist at Iowa State University I'm
here to talk to you today about citing
and building a quality pond as you can
see here we're in a watershed this is
the future site of a pond and some
things that you need to consider
whenever building your pond is the
amount of soil that you're gonna have to
move because that's the major expense
component of building upon as well as
the volume of water that you want to try
to hold in there now we recommend that
your ponds be at least eight feet deep
15 feets probably better this is to
prevent winter kills you're going to
want to make sure that your your dam is
gonna have a lot of good clay in there
very little sand so that it can packs
very well and holds water you're also
going to want to check out the watershed
and find natural pinch points so right
here we have three ridges coming
together and we're gonna take the
shortest distance across there to hold
the most water for the least amount of
soil moved other things that you want to
take into consideration is what's in
your watershed so as you can see here
we're in a prairie this is going to do a
really good job of stopping soil
sediments from coming in as well as
reducing nutrient loads so you don't
have the aquatic plant problems another
thing you want to consider is the
construction the shape of that dam so
you want to have a three to one slope in
other words for every one foot of rise
you want to have three foot of run
that's going to establish some aquatic
plants on the edge but by the time you
get about ten feet offshore you're gonna
be at a depth where you're low enough to
where you're not promoting aquatic
plants to grow other things you can see
here we have trees in the watershed and
we can cut those trees off and create
really good fish habitat and that's
gonna congregate those fish in that area
so other questions that you might have
you can contact me again my name is
Allen Pattillo I'm your fisheries and
aquaculture extension specialist thanks
and good luck out there